le décor a beau être un chanteur la
cible plutôt ambitieuse son clan qui
répondent aux besoins des canadiens la
façon précise de l'atteindre reste
encore un peu flou car pour réduire ses
émissions de 730 443 mégatonnes en huit
ans le gouvernement trudeau doit
s'attaquer aux secteurs les plus
polluants entre autres celui du pétrole
et du gaz responsables de 26% des
émissions pis
mais ottawa ne donne pas d'échéancier
pour un éventuel plafond d'émissions il
doit d'abord discuté avec l'industrie on
en demande énormément à l'industrie
pétrolière faux répond l'opposition
bloquiste mais un plan de réduction qui
nous permet pas de plafonner la
production d'audi moins de la réduire
dans un dans un avenir rapproché mais
c'est pas tout à fait crédible
d'ailleurs même si le canada s'est doté
d'une projection global de 40 % de
réduction elle n'est que de 31 % pour le
secteur pétrolier et gazier
la rapidité avec laquelle on peut
déployer des mesures que ce soit des
mesures technologiques font en sorte que
l'on pouvait pas simplement prendre un
chiffre et dire ça va être le même
chiffre pour tout le monde l'action
climatique c'est un effort d'équipé
c'est décevant de constater que
plusieurs joueurs sont restés sur le
banc de touche notamment les secteurs
pétrolier et gazier même le npd qui
vient de signer une entente avec les
libéraux se dit déçu du plan et promet
de faire pression sur le gouvernement on
a besoin de plus d'actions des actions
plus fort autres grands secteurs
polluants les transports qui constitue
25% des émissions le gouvernement
fédéral promet d'ici 2030 60 % des
voitures vendues au pays seront des
véhicules propres mais il restera encore
bien des voitures à essence sur nos
routes croit cet expert le parc
automobile qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est un
parc automobile essentiellement composé
de camions légers et qui est en
croissance et ils ce sont des véhicules
qui dans une large mesure vont encore
être là dans huit ans malgré ces
critiques plusieurs experts notent que
la feuille de route présentée par le
gouvernement entre d'oreste plus
complète et détaillée qu'elle ne l'a été
dans le passé mais est-ce que ce plan
sera suffisant pour atteindre nos cibles
d'ici 2030 difficile à dire et si
laurence martin radio canada ottawa